well just like I said before anytime
there's a sequel remake i do a fast
little review of it so this is my facile
review of The Parent Trap remake this
was of course one of the major
introductions of Lindsay Lohan and one
of the big films that turned her into a
huge star and yes I know there's a lot
of jokes you can make about her what
happened to her childhood she used to be
so cute bla bla bla bla bla but taking
all that aside let's just look at the
performance as it is it's still a really
good performance in my opinion she's
just as good as Hayley Mills the
technology has really been updated to
this time they can actually touch each
other not have to be at opposite sides
of the screen and you know all those
obvious tricks the funny thing about
this movie though is unlike other
remakes instead of changing too much I
don't think they change enough it's
still the exact same story they meet at
camp they switch places then the parents
find out and then they have to get rid
of the really snooty wife that he's
gonna marry is just like why we know the
faults of the first film why didn't they
just get rid of this character the film
is so similar in design and it's setup I
kind of wonder why it even need to be
remade was it just to update the
technology to tell a story that they
thought was already perfect did they
just think Lindsay Lohan was too
frigging adorable and they had to give
her her own movie a movie where you
could have two over she's that friggin
adorable I don't know the reason but as
a flick it's again okay it's about as
good as the first one in my opinion you
could see either of these and probably
get the exact same reaction they both
have a charming couple they both have a
good child actress I say the only real
upgrade is the technology in that the
effects are so much better so take it
for what it's worth I know it's weird
it's very strange I come across a film
where I have almost the exact same
opinion of them but that's kind of what
I got here
I guess it just comes from I was never
that invested in the original story at
least enough to care a whole great deal
about it and well yeah it's kind of the
same thing here which isn't bad it's
fine
it's just for me it's nothing that
spectacular you go to see some neat
effects and a good child
that's about it and if that's what
you're looking for this one's a fine one
to check out rent both compare the two
and see for yourself
you